el síndrome de ovario poliquístico
también llamado psc o ese es un
desequilibrio de las hormonas sexuales
femeninas
y los ovarios forman parte del sistema
reproductor femenino junto con las
trompas de falopio
el útero
y la vagina
y sus ovarios contienen sus óvulos
estos óvulos son inmaduros y se
almacenan en pequeñas estructuras tiene
este líquido llamadas folículos
y la glándula pituitaria situada en la
base del cerebro produce hormonas que
dirigen la función de sus ovarios
cada mes la glándula pituitaria secreta
la hormona estimulante del folículo o
efe sh y la hormona luteinizante lh
hacia el torrente sanguíneo
después de que estas hormonas llegan a
los ovarios varios cientos de óvulos
inmaduros comienzan a madurar
incrementando el tamaño de los folículos
a medida que los óvulos maduran los
folículos secretan estrógeno la
principal hormona sexual femenina una
vez que la cantidad de estrógeno en la
sangre alcanza un cierto nivel
y la pituitaria envía una gran cantidad
de hormona luteinizante a los ovarios
haciendo que el folículo más maduro se
abra y libere su óvulo en un proceso
llamado ovulación
el óvulo liberado viaja por la trompa de
falopio donde espera la fertilización
con el tiempo los folículos inmaduros y
los óvulos restantes se disuelven
si el óvulo no es fecundado el óvulo y
el revestimiento del útero se desprende
durante el siguiente periodo menstrual
si usted padece del síndrome de ovario
poliquístico su glándula pituitaria
puede liberar altas cantidades anormales
de hormona luteinizante hacia el
torrente sanguíneo lo que altera su
ciclo menstrual normal
como consecuencia los folículos no
maduran y la ovulación no ocurre lo que
puede llevar a la infertilidad algunos
de los folículos inmaduros no se
disuelven y permanecen como sacos llenos
de líquido o quistes
además el médico puede encontrar que su
sangre tiene niveles altos de insulina
una hormona producida por el páncreas
el exceso de insulina en combinación con
altos niveles de hormona luteinizante
puede conducir a un exceso de producción
de una hormona masculina llamada
testosterona en los ovarios los altos
niveles anormales de testosterona
detienen la ovulación lo que puede
llevar a la infertilidad
y los altos niveles de testosterona
también causan muchas de las
características físicas asociadas al
síndrome de ovario poliquístico tales
como el acné y el crecimiento anormal de
vello
y padecer del síndrome de ovario
poliquístico aumenta el riesgo de
diabetes tipo 2 debido a un exceso de
insulina y resistencia a la misma
y enfermedades del corazón presión
arterial alta anormalidades de
colesterol en la sangre
y cáncer de endometrio
puesto que no hay cura para el síndrome
de ovario poliquístico el médico puede
recomendar uno o más medicamentos para
tratar sus síntomas tales como los
anticonceptivos hormonales que aparte de
prevenir el embarazo también regulan el
ciclo menstrual y reducen la producción
de testosterona en los ovarios
los medicamentos antiandrogénicos que
reducen el crecimiento anormal de vello
y acné los medicamentos para la diabetes
tales como la met morfina que reducen
los niveles de insulina y regula el
ciclo
y los medicamentos para la fertilidad
que estimulan la ovulación por lo que
puede quedar embarazada
si desea quedar embarazada y los
medicamentos para la fertilidad no han
tenido éxito en el restablecimiento de
la ovulación el médico puede recomendar
la incisión ovárica laparoscópica
durante el procedimiento
el cirujano insertará una pequeña aguja
dentro del ovario y usará una corriente
eléctrica para destruir las pequeñas
áreas de tejido ovárico
donde se produce la testosterona
con el tiempo la producción de
testosterona disminuye y puede ocurrir
la ovulación